[Music]
did you know that the average American
claims to have about four close friends
and the greater majority of us have
between two and six really that makes
sense
wait what does that mean so close
friends is defined as as someone that
you cannot imagine like with that Oh
like a homey homey relatives and spouses
can also camp homey homey tree this is a
good thing yeah
cuz it's like it if you have 30 close
friends I don't know what that means
it's you got me you got homey you got
friends you have acquaintances yeah
there's levels to this yeah yeah but
people for me it's like if I can call
you two in the morning I think you'll
come help me fix my tire or whatever the
[ __ ] going on
then you're my clothes clothes
absolutely yeah I literally only have
like five or six yeah I consider like
that I guess triple-a is my clothes
clothes you know they come through in
the clutch yeah I told people last year
on my podcast I was like I'm not making
new friends in 2020 yeah I'm not adding
in if new fall number 19 new
acquaintances nothing oh you can follow
me on IG but I'm not exchanging numbers
with anybody new in 2020 I don't want to
add any new birthdays to my calendar I
don't want to be able to check on people
I'm not doing it
no how would I what if she's so [ __ ]
hot and she can keep a secret
I really just don't give a [ __ ] or
whatever else methods like to hear but I
was gonna make a movie with you but you
don't wanna be my friend too bad I met
with my last year just like this how
will it yeah yeah I'm good man I'm not
doing it I'm tired
but what if Roseann was like I want to
make a comeback to here can we make a
video together
Rosie Roseanne Barr ya know or Rosie
O'Donnell or Rosie O'Donnell know love
them hard pass
hard passes really I was just gonna say
that 5% of those said that they had no
clothes
at all I feel like the numbers bigger
for younger people
that's desc yes that's the people that
have botnet that's why is this right
there exactly so and also five percent
of those studied so that they had more
than eight very close friends I think
one of the things that might even
contribute to that to I remember like as
a kid when everyone used to play outside
and when you just didn't have anything
to do you just met up with people right
and then you just sit in front in the
front yard and do jack [ __ ] and you're
able to just talk and be so close with
each other I know people have the
internet these days but spending time
over the internet to me is not the same
as spending it and real I don't know man
because there's people that are like
long time Xbox friends and they're like
become you're like best man for their
wedding those just met her close friend
of 15 years that she had only known
online and they made a new person for
the first time and it was like an
instant like with respective O's I would
never met that a lot right because she
made them to Xbox we said wait him no
it's a girl no it's like it's like not
like it was maple as like a childhood
friend that you guys went from like
first grade to like eighth grade way
yeah or this Jake I've been studying
that new dynamic and friendship with
this new it's not a new generation it's
actually our generation and younger
people that are like online friends for
years and years and they end up being
closer than some of the friends that
they grew up with or even um really like
what is it like a loving really intimate
relations yeah all my lover's yeah yeah
and then just never make it see how they
can be closer because since there's not
the anonymity part but there's at least
like some protective layer where like I
feel like people can be a lot more
vulnerable Oh they'd be more themselves
yeah more than sozin they are because
there's still that space for them for
the other person to reply mm-hmm what's
a close friend describe a close friend
so someone that you can't imagine life
without so like cuz I'm also thinking
about someone that you can like I'm
picturing my childhood best best friends
they're the ones that are like you
confide everything in those are the ones
that are like I've
I hate my parents if I have to run away
can I come sleep at your house with that
type of stuff so when you're like that
tight you know and they know the
day-to-day of all the strugglers are
going through because I don't I don't
make any friends online it's hard for me
to imagine people getting that tight and
like someone not only see my parents
beat the [ __ ] out of me I mean me
telling the story of my parents being
the shadow me
they also witnessed my parents beating
the [ __ ] out of me so they see that in
person they go oh [ __ ] I see the
situation part bartson right I remember
having close friends on AOL and we ended
up like hanging out and one of them is
isn't is is my buddy James who used to
film for JK films yeah
and it's because I really wanted to get
into hip-hop at the moment and get into
like breakdancing and like recording
music and all that stuff and then I
could only do it on the forms and then
from the forms we're going on - like I
like instant messenger and then we were
like telling each other like tips and
trades for like a year and we met up and
we became friends like he taught me how
to like get a record and then get beats
from the record a word so but then do
the other conversations around the skill
set or like around the hobby right you
would talk about family life he would
talk about everything else just like a
regular friendship would you say the
friendship was stronger after you met in
person though or before I want to know
cuz it's been so many years ago but I
think for me making friends online is
pretty normal so it's been so many years
that I've done it
mm-hmm that I yeah I think there's got
to be a point where you do get closer
maybe when you see each other
face-to-face but I do know that a newer
generation of people can be friends for
a decade all online and never meet each
other if you like their real friends
that made friends online too but like
the the deepest level of friendship is
the part that I'm like damn that's crazy
if Bo's is indeed that tight with
someone that she's been friends with for
15 years oh my that's [ __ ] sick I've
never experienced it but that's just
hard for me to understand how tight they
can become I think that if you can
confine in someone because that part
it's like you don't even know this
person and you know that there's no
consequence they're not gonna turn
around and talk [ __ ] and they're far
away you feel safer I think
I think if you if you have someone that
you can confide in or like from from the
aspect of online versus are not versus
but being the same as somebody that you
grew up with who saw the [ __ ] did you go
went through like the traumatic
experiences and they were there for you
in that moment those experiences are
what build that long lasting friendship
and when the friendship is real like you
guys don't even have to talk every day
yeah or you can sit in silence together
yeah oh my god my two best friends Dana
and Ervin like we literally were in a
hotel room one time each one of us was
doing something completely different for
like two hours no one said anything we
were mad at each other nobody had an
attitude we were all just that's the
best coexisting in each other's energy
and presence how you would be anyone
yeah it was amazing and you I don't have
a lot of people that can do that wet
that can sit in silence sometimes it's
nice to like comics I don't have a lot
of comments cuz sometimes Cummings or
not I turn it off no yeah bro just be a
person yeah that's the worst [ __ ] though
I'd be the funniest in the room or don't
let it be a tick around I didn't want to
yeah it was like could you not I mean
right now in a popsicle what a fork a
knife this book that says it takes
between 40 and 60 hours to create a
casual friendship and over 200 hours to
become a best friend and so they were
saying that there was this one study
that showed that the happiest people at
the end of their lives tended to their
relationships they actively worked to
replace co-workers with new playmates
and they put in the time so pretty much
you're saying here too is also that
friendships affect your health and lack
big time also affecting my mom doesn't
have any friends and it's sad is she
coughing a lot say no I got sick
recently and I coughed a lot I think the
more friends you would have maybe the
more she could have gotten sick only is
that why he's trying to say so no it's
fine but you can say if you're lonely
not lowly he was coughing no point being
yeah so my mother doesn't have very many
friends and so that it's depressing to
see what does she confide in and like
talk with well she tries to call me but
I only pick up how come she can't make
friends it's yeah it's sad to talk to
her yeah I get I get I'm the exact same
way like me and my mom probably now more
via text than we do over the phone and I
know it's bad because I know you know
God forbid something happened she's not
available to just call i'ma feel some
type of way about it and didn't take
advantage of these times but like I'm
still working on being expressing
unconditional love yeah and like cuz you
guys got history
well yeah I moved out super early so
like you know and I don't hold it
against it but it's just like it's like
what we gonna talk about like no their
fault yeah I don't know what to talk
about really yeah the same relationship
with my mom too and she constantly tells
me like like me hey you cuz we had like
an uglier relationship and then now
we're older we're trying like a minute
yeah we you know just talk [ __ ] for fun
sometimes it's your job to be
entertaining you're boring say be more
entertaining and I'll talk to you thing
she always tells me like you know right
now I'm alive what's gonna happen once
I'm gone like we're not you'll be a dead
boring ass hey man did you did you sign
the wheel did all the paperwork for this
earnest we don't bi does she does she
guilt trip you that you're not giving
her enough time oh my mom does my mom
know I think she understands why we
don't have the time together is just
that I think she feels guilty that like
a lot of her past actions has really
caused a rift in our relationship where
it's really hard to mend it even though
she's trying I've you know I'm trying
she's like people give me what are you
like what I think I haven't yes I she
said please forgive me yes
well I think I haven't yet compensated
for is the fact that now I'm a made man
and I put my wife first above all things
yeah man
I'm like damn so I got my mom and her
stuff and I used to be my mom's golden
light for her stuff saying and that's
harder now to do because I got to be mr.
positive man at home with my wife and
okay and pull it apart but but Nikki's
not a burden at all it's actually made
she makes me better but then I got that
I gotta be mr. positive at home like I
got to be myself at home but then it's
hard to do that when I think about
sadness because you also have a certain
amount of energy right now it's being
spread all over me this much space for
sadness and it's already been filled got
hard it's hard and and black coffee time
with Nikki actually lifts me up but then
I can't be myself necessarily around
icky if I'm if I'm having a sad time
maybe with so how do you get a bigger
bug I'm figuring we need a 7/11 mug
[ __ ] meditation [ __ ] out of the
universe when I'm up there I'm like I
don't care about the whole body hmm yeah
but I mean with this article here say
that people that tend to have close
relationships with friends they tend to
live longer and they're happier so yeah
I mean make a friend get friends be a
better son man I need to be a better son
or what you can do is figure out who
will you really enjoy your time with and
spend more time with them I like I like
Steve's I like Steve's bags you're gonna
you're gonna end up waiting on all your
family yeah I like Steve better because
if you go where it's easy yeah the hard
part
yep but I have family members I love and
then you're lucky you're the one lucky
ones I just spend time with daddy take a
little break and I come back when
they're good I always tell my cuz I was
like you know what I only cost $300 have
somebody killed professionally right oh
wow
but I feel like they're gonna turn if
they can come if you want more I mean
you want a better you know product you
got to spend more force so 500 I rather
have
mouse for friends who Mouse they don't
do my SIA Dona they don't live very long
that's perfect three birthdays goodbye
it's like it's like a lease of a car but
way less of a commitment
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]